[Music]
how do you dream about changing the
world
maybe it's by starting a company that
helps women look and feel their best
creating hundreds of jobs and
internships
maybe you're successful in manufacturing
first before you turn to philanthropy
changing children's lives forever
or maybe it's by getting elected to the
west wing tonight I'd like to suggest a
different but just as a rewarding option
serving in your local government
sometimes it feels hard to separate
government from a TV comedy and when you
can't take government seriously it's
hard to care about it or value it early
feedback for this talk included could
you find a different word for government
it turns people off when you say it so
much I haven't found any good synonyms
for government yet but tonight I want to
make the case that you should take it
seriously
and consider getting involved with your
City Hall or State Capitol because state
and local government is the most
impactful organization that you've never
cared about and all of you smart
talented people should care about an
organization that moves billions of
dollars and affects millions of lives in
our community right now participation in
local government is low across the board
only 19 percent of Americans have
contacted a local official in the last
year only 24 percent have attended a
local public meeting those rates are
even lower amongst young Americans but
when I asked my friends here if they'd
consider getting involved I hear things
like it's not
the highest and best use of their time
or that government is slow and
inefficient there's this perception that
your frustrating experience at the DMV
would translate into the impact that you
could have by getting involved and I
can't promise you that government offers
the autonomy that you might have at a
startup or will be as fast-moving as a
tech company but I also don't think any
of us would like it if our local police
force or fire department started using
move fast and break things as their
motto
slowness in government is a design
feature it prevents any one of us from
consolidating power and allows all of us
to have a say in how we are governed and
I can promise you that the slowness that
you sometimes see in government does not
translate into the impact that you could
have by getting involved there are three
reasons why influence scale and talent
let's talk about influence take Cameron
Johnson who graduated from the GSB in
2008 these days Cameron is the director
of product innovation at Netflix
he's also the vice mayor of San Carlos
California during the day Cameron works
on video streaming when you turn your
field phone from portrait to landscape
mode at night he goes to transportation
board meetings where he decides on
policies for roads public transit and
autonomous vehicles for the 7 million
people who live in the South Bay Cameron
works on your user experience on the
Netflix app and on the 101 I've seen
this ability to have immediate influence
firsthand when I was 25 years old I
worked with the mayor of Salt Lake
County on a project to help the homeless
and men leaving the county jail at 25 I
got to chair committees coordinate data
sharing agreements and launched an 11
million dollar project that provided job
training rehabilitation services and
housing for over 300 men so what's the
multiplier effect of that influence
let's talk about scale you could for
example go work at the Gates Foundation
which just gave 1.7 billion dollars to
education that's scale right the man
himself Bill Gates actually said it best
in his Foundation's annual letter while
our foundation is the largest in the
world the amount we give is small
compared to government the Gates
Foundation
endowment a forty four billion dollars
is less than the seventy six billion
dollars that the state of California
spends on its public school system in
one year and it's not just education if
you care about health care energy
transportation chances are that the
government deploys far more resources
than philanthropy does lastly I want to
talk about talent there's a term in
baseball called value over replacement
player it argues that a batter's value
isn't the absolute number of runs he
hits but the runs he hits over the
average player who would have replaced
him think about your own value over a
replacement for example if you're going
into consulting you'll be joining the
nine hundred and eighty five other GSB
graduates since 2003 so what happens
when you leave Bane or BCG in a few
years they'll likely replace you with
someone ninety five percent is good from
HBS the same is not true of government
since 2003 only twenty two of us or half
of 1% have gone directly into government
out of over thirty three thousand alums
in the lam Knight directory only eighty
eight are involved in state and local
government that means that our cities
and states just don't have that many
people who think about traffic and
congestion with an Operations
perspective or run a local public health
campaign with a marketing background or
even higher key personnel with
recommendations from Joel Peterson your
value over a placement could be high as
you leave the GSB you're looking for
ways to have impact quickly it's why
people do search funds to run an
organization a few years after
graduating it's why people do consulting
to influence large powerful
organizations
it's why people do private equity to
deploy large pools of capital to improve
organizations you can do all three of
these things a mile down the road at
City Hall I've spent this whole talk
talking about what you could do for a
government but in the end I'd ask that
you value government for what it does
for you
local government takes out your trash it
repairs the roads that you drive on and
pays the policeman who pulls you over
for speeding it likely runs the schools
that you attended as a child and the
schools that your children will attend
it decides whether you have a composting
bin or whether to utilize renewable
energy for millions of residents it runs
hospitals provides health care and cares
for the elderly these essential services
aren't just things that happen to exist
in our communities they were developed
and they can be improved by you and by
me Teddy Roosevelt once said far and
away the best prize that life has to
offer is the chance to work hard at work
worth doing you all have a lot of
options in how you change the world but
I hope that you consider public service
it is hard work but it is work worth
doing
[Music]